how much luck is required in a chess
game
that way is it to me this is a question
yes but why to me
I actually feel quite strange in this
building because of its name I believe
it's called Call Of Fame
and I feel like for me there should be a
separate building called the Hall of
Shame
[Applause]
do you think he's the biggest Contender
for winning the candidates I don't know
I'm not a bookmaker
you know I always try not to watch
Sevilla during the tournament because
he's too brilliant for me and I
and I start to feel miserable and listen
sometimes you go to smoke in your
opinion makes a move so I will run there
and say like oh my God I'm three minutes
for 20 minutes like ah